I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has
officially entered the 2024 presidential
race after announcing his bid in a
Twitter conversation with Elon Musk
governing is not entertainment it's not
about building a brand or virtue
signaling it is about delivering results
and our results in Florida have been
Second To None we can and we must
deliver big results for America after a
big win in the midterms and a successful
legislative session in Florida DeSantis
is looking to take his politics National
going head-to-head with former president
Donald Trump for the GOP nomination they
are the top two contenders for the
Republican nomination at this point no
one else comes close but moving from
State politics to a national stage
presents its own challenges for DeSantis
so what should we expect from the
governor and what challenges lie ahead
thank you
once close allies the relationship
between DeSantis and Trump has evolved
greatly over time we
Ronda said
Trump endorsed DeSantis in the 2018
gubernatorial election Mr President I
look forward to working with you to
advance Florida's priorities I think
you're going to get tired of me calling
you asking you for things for Florida
they felt similarly on a lot of issues
DeSantis sort of championed those issues
back in Florida the president had a real
Ally there that really came off the
wheels recently as the governor asserted
himself politically and began to look at
a presidential run now Trump's attitude
toward DeSantis has soured often jabbing
the governor about sagging approval
ratings let's say there it is Trump at
71 Rhonda sanctimonious at 10 he feels
that the governor is disloyal that Ron
DeSantis is not showing him proper
Respect by challenging him for the for
the presidency
DeSantis has largely avoided responding
to the former president's attacks I
don't know how to spell the sanctimonies
I don't really know what it means but I
you know I kind of like it's long it's
got a lot of valve I mean so we'd go
with that that's fine you know you can
call me you can call me whatever you
want I mean just as long as you you know
also call me a winner in order to win
the Republican nomination Rhonda Sanchez
is going to need a lot of trump
supporters so alienating those with
hard-hitting attacks against the former
president could turn those people off
since winning the 2018 election
desantis's popularity among voters has
exploded in Florida illustrated by his
Landslide 19-point re-election win in
the November midterms
and his popularity continued to grow
after he delivered several conservative
policy victories during the last
legislative session in Florida from
restrictions on drag shows to limiting
spending on diversity programs in
colleges DeSantis policies have made
national headlines and will likely serve
as the backbone for his presidential
campaign as he tries to win over a wider
range of Voters he'll be able to say
look how effective I was I got X Y and Z
done versus you know some of the
struggles that that Trump as president
had getting his agenda passed other
bills endorsed by DeSantis include
allowing concealed handguns without a
permit and a strict six-week abortion
ban
while those policies may serve DeSantis
while in the primaries they could also
prove to be a challenge for him in the
general election
in a Wall Street Journal poll asking
about the right to carry a concealed
handgun without a permit 56 of
Republican primary voters said they
support that right while Nationwide 65
percent of overall voters were in
opposition and for the six-week abortion
ban 68 percent of Republican primary
voters favored the ban but 53 percent of
Voters overall opposed it the abortion
issue is very complex it's controversial
six weeks is seen is pretty extreme by a
lot of people
DeSantis is also preparing to challenge
the incumbent President Joe Biden who
along with Trump has experience running
in presidential elections and winning
them
the census is not tested on a national
stage he doesn't have the experience
dealing with world leaders or or major
Global issues so that that'll be
something that both Trump and Biden
would use against Ron DeSantis DeSantis
now joins a growing swath of Republican
candidates in the race including Trump
former South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley and South Carolina Senator Tim
Scott with the potential for others
including former vice president Mike
Pence who may announce in the coming
months right now it's it's down to
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis it's their
their fight to lose Republicans are
hungry for someone who can get something
done there's a number of other
Republicans that are vying for this and
they're going to be looking especially
to see if Ron DeSantis stumbles
essentially if you boil down Ron
desantis's argument is I'm effective I
can carry on the agenda that Donald
Trump kind of started but actually get
it passed
[Music]